على الجانب الاخر من هذه الحدود تمتد
السيطره الميليشيات المواليه لايران داخل
سوريا بين محافظتي السويداء ودرعا
المتاخمهتين للحدود الاردنيه حيث تتزايد
عمليات التهريب الى الجار الجنوبي بالطرق
الاردن اعلن عن احباط محاوله تهريب جديده
لكنها ليست كسابقاتها من حيث الاسلوب اذ
حاول القائمون على المحاوله تهريب اسلحه
بطائره مسيره مفخخه امر يعتبر سابقه لم
تشهدها المنطقه من قبل وفقا لمصادر في
الجيش الاردني الطائره تم اعدادها بطريقه
مفخخه في حال تم ضبطها من قبل عناصر حرس
الحدود كانت تحمل بندقيه من طراز
واربع قنابل يدويه
تمتد الحدود بين الاردن وسوريا لمسافه 375
كيلومترا تحتوي على معبر اثنين هما معبر
الرمثا ومعبر جابر او معبر ونصيب الاكثر
حركه وازدحام في داخل السوري تنتشر على
طول هذه الحدود ميليشيا حزب الله والفصائل
المواليه لايران تدير عمليه تهريب
المخدرات والاسلحه الى الجانب الاردني
بينما يتحمل الجيش الاردني حراسه وحمايه
الحدود من جانب واحد وفقا لمعلومات
متقاطعه العام الماضي سجل رقما قياسيا في
عمليات التهريب وحجم المواد المهربه حيث
ضبط الاردن 16 مليون حبه مخدره خلال 45
يوما فقط وهي كميه تعادل ما تم ضبطه خلال
2021 باكمله
عمليات التهريب المخدرات المنظمه اخذت
بالاستفحال عقب السيطره الميليشيات
الايرانيه على المنطقه الجنوبيه من سوريا
عام 2021 ليس الى الاردن فحسب بل الى كل
اسقاع الارض